with all your movie success and writing
success and i've talked to you in the
past about how you started out what i
like about you is you're such a regular
guy and and by that i mean your plan is
to go to the comic book store today yeah
and then wait wait what were the two
places you go into the comic book store
and then you're going to tokyo toy toy
tokyo yeah
what is the comic book store you like uh
midtown comics is a pretty good comic
book what kind of comics do you read i
read all kind of comics i read like
superhero comics uh marvel comics and i
read uh kind of i follow writers more
than like the series there's like who
are your faves uh garth ennis is one of
my favorite writers see part of part of
the problem with me is yeah like i
haven't kept i used to when i was a kid
i had every comic yeah and now i haven't
kept up and then and then when i get
these compilation books yeah i read the
comics i love comic books yeah but then
to go buy individual copies of comics
because you can't you don't know where
the beginning of the story you're in the
middle of it yeah how do you keep up do
you have a subscription to these comics
no you i'll try to like pick them up as
they start or uh or sometimes you can go
back and catch up on the ones that you
but yeah i mean they they're always
starting like little mini series is so
that's kind of what i what i tried right
so so you try to grab the entire series
yeah definitely i don't like to jump
into a story in the middle but most of
these writers now through like smaller
labels release like their own like they
call them like create our own series and
and there'll be like six comic runs of
kind of just little original things so
when you go to the comic book store you
say to the guy listen yeah i don't want
any nonsense
i want to have a complete story don't
[ __ ] with me right right listen i'm a
celebrity i know my [ __ ] are there a lot
of people in there uh sometimes did they
get excited hey there's seth rogan
looking at comics sometimes comic book
fans are generally kind of shy and nerdy
in general so they they're not upping
your [ __ ] too much you get specially
they go home and say hey mom i'm not a
loser exactly
he was really high and unique exactly
the same thing he's doing
one time i was in a bookstore actually
and uh a like 14 year old kid came up to
me and he's like he was holding two
books he's like you're my [ __ ] idol
man look at what two books i'm buying
and it was a book about screenplay
writing and an encyclopedia of marijuana
yeah like you're on the right track man
you get special treatment at the comic
book store i mean do people uh at the
store try to assist you and help you
sometimes they do they'll tell me they
can if there's anything i need to order
they'll put it on back order for me
because it's quite charming that you
still do this i mean you could go on the
internet and buy comic books you don't
need to necessarily be at this point but
you're looking for new stuff now you
want something i like uh i don't know i
like having you like drinks
what is toy tokyo what is that all about
and what are you doing there uh it's
like uh they sell like vinyl japanese
toys i kind of
you collect that stuff i do a while ago
i got into uh
a lot of like i don't know actually
making me sound like a [ __ ] huge nerd
uh no not action figures i collect like
a lot of artists i like make these like
vinyl japanese or that not not some of
them are made in china and japan but a
lot of artists i like make these vinyl
toys and i've been collecting those for
years where do you display the vinyl
toys uh my office has a lot of them
they're kind of around the house it's
kind of a battle to where i could get
them
and i like it yeah and it's like pop art
to me that's why it's like they're
they're it's like pop art but you seem
like a guy who's really sort of at the
same point you have a lot of friends and
isn't that but then there's you're
solitary seth rogen he writes he smokes
and he has his toys yes exactly my
comics and my toys